نبدا اذا مساء العربيه بخبر فني قوي ومع
فنان يعود بقوه الكلام طبعا عن محمد منير
الذي قال في المقابله خاصه مع العربيه يضع
صوته لدعم التقارب بين دول النيل منير عاد
هذا العام ليضع بصمته المعهوده والمتفرده
على تترات مسلسلات رمضان 2023 بعد غيابا
لاكثر من 11 عاما النجم يشارك في السباق
الرمضاني بعملين قام بغناء تتر الخاص بهما
وهما مسلسل عمله نادره ومسلسل سرعه الكينج
منير كشف للعربيه نت عن طلبه ابن الرئيس
السيسي دعم ورعايه اكبر مشروع فني ومهرجان
لدول حاضنين لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات